hey guys I wanted to show you something
kind of cool a little bit of a humble
brag but yes I'm hoping this gym in kind
of the middle of nowhere doesn't really
look like like a residential kind of
neighborhood kind of sketchy I don't
want to show you something so even
though you know
don't let your circumstances make you
feel like you're like you can't sell
usually it's just your pitch it's like
how sketchy does this look right
I'd be sketched out so we were coming up
these stairs they're like these windows
oh my god what am I getting into like
what is this like I'm saying yeah this
is gonna be a gym it's gonna be amazing
look we got some stuff here here's a
bathroom that I don't even know here's
some stuff here's some stuff what's
going on
hold on so the other size like weight is
in apartment I don't even know is it
sort of it's like in the middle of the
living room there's some paintings on
the wall and this is it right but
somehow here's the cool part these are
all 500 are bills so you can sell
wherever you want so uh don't let that
stop you